OKAY. WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND GET STARTED. WELCOME TO
BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT, WE NEED AN
AUTHOR. SO WE'RE GOING TO HANG
OUT HERE UNTIL WE. UNTIL WE GET
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHO'D LIKE
THEIR BILL. MOVED THROUGH
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT.
WHILE WE DO NOT HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, WE DO HAVE A QUORUM OF
SENATORS. SO I'M GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND TAKE THE ROLE SO WE
CAN GET GOING WITH SETTING OUR
QUORUM IN PLACE. AND IF YOU'RE
AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER IN THE SWING
SPACE WITH A BILL IN BUSINESS,
PROFESSIONS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE, COME ON
DOWN. IN THE MEANTIME, MADAM
PRESIDENT, MADAM CHAIR, WE HAVE
A STOWAWAY. I KNOW ASHBY HERE.
ASHBY HERE. NGUYEN. ALVARADO.
GIL ARCHULETA HERE. ARCHULETA
HERE. BECKER HERE. BECKER. HERE.
DODD. EGGMAN. GLASER MENGIBAR.
MENGIBAR. HERE. NILO HERE. NILO.
HERE. ROTH. ROTH. HERE SMALLEY.
CUEVAS. WILK. PRESENT. WILK
PRESENT.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. NO ONE NOTICED
MY DAUGHTER SNEAK IN AND OUT OF
THE CHAMBER. THAT'S GREAT. WE DO
HAVE A QUORUM. STILL LACKING AN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, THOUGH WE DO
HAVE A MEASURE ON CONSENT. WE
CAN TAKE UP THE CONSENT CALENDAR
. LET'S DO IT. MOVED OKAY. AB
1988. MAN MURATSUCHI. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS.
ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN
ALVARADO. GIL. ARCHULETA.
ARCHULETA. AYE BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. DODD EGGMAN. GLAZER.
MENGIBAR NHIÀU. MENGIBAR. AYE.
NILO NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. AYE.
WILK. AYE. YOU CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. THIS IS
CONSENT. WHEN NGUYEN. AYE.
ALVARADO. GIL DODD. EGGMAN.
GLAZER. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. ALL
RIGHT, WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
AND WE DO HAVE AN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. WELCOME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MAIENSCHEIN, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT YOUR AB
2248 TO US? THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
CALIFORNIA'S BEEN A NATIONAL
LEADER IN ELIMINATING THE USE OF
PUPPY MILLS, WHICH ARE DESIGNED
TO MAXIMIZE PROFITS AT THE
EXPENSE OF THE ANIMALS IN THEIR
POSSESSION. ANIMALS ARE
GENERALLY KEPT IN OVERCROWDED
AND UNSANITARY CONDITIONS
WITHOUT ADEQUATE CARE, FOOD,
WATER, OR SOCIALIZATION. AFTER
CALIFORNIA BANNED THE SALE OF
PUPPY MILL ANIMALS AND PET
STORES, THE BUSINESS LARGELY
SHIFTED ONLINE TO CONTINUE
SELLING PETS TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. THESE SITES DISPLAY
PHOTOS AND PROVIDE ONLY MINIMAL
INFORMATION ABOUT A PUPPY, SUCH
AS THEIR AGE AND BREED. A
VISITOR TO THE SITE IS PROMOTED
TO PAY IN FULL OR RESERVE THE
PUPPY BY PLACING A DEPOSIT. THIS
NONREFUNDABLE PAYMENT IS
REQUIRED BEFORE THE COMPANY WILL
PROVIDE ANYTHING OTHER THAN
GENERIC INFORMATION TO THE
CONSUMER. IN SHORT, THESE
BUSINESSES COLLECT HUNDREDS OF
DOLLARS FOR CONSUMERS FOR JUST
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS. IF A CONSUMER LEARNS
THE NAME OF THE BREEDER AND HAS
CONCERNS, THEY MUST MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE CONTRACT OR LOSE THEIR
DEPOSIT. CONSUMER COMPLAINTS
DESCRIBE BAIT AND SWITCH
TACTICS, WHICH INCLUDE RECEIVING
PETS THAT ARE SICK OR DIFFERENT
THAN WHAT WAS PICTURED AT THE
POINT OF SALE. THE NONREFUNDABLE
DEPOSITS ARE PREDATORY AND USED
PURELY AS A SALES TACTIC. TO
ADDRESS THIS, AB 2248 STATES A
CONTRACT FOR THE SALE OF A DOG
OR CAT IS VOID IF IT REQUIRES A
NONREFUNDABLE DEPOSIT AND DOES
NOT DISCLOSE THE SOURCE OF THE
PET. THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
SELLERS TO REFUND THE DEPOSIT
WITHIN 30 DAYS. IF THE CONTRACT
IS VOTED, IS VETOED, VOIDED, I
SHOULD SAY, OR VETOED, I GUESS.
THANK YOU. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. AS THE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM ASPCA IS
STUCK IN TRAFFIC, BUT THEY WOULD
STRONGLY AGREE WITH WHAT I JUST
SAID. SO WE BELIEVE YOU. OKAY SO
AND LET'S SEE. SO YOUR LEAD
WITNESS IS STUCK IN TRAFFIC.
WE'LL GIVE THEM A PASS. ASSUME
THEY WOULD SAY GLOWING THINGS
ABOUT YOUR BILL. IS THERE A LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE. IF THERE IS ANYONE IN THE
ROOM WHO'D LIKE TO COME FORWARD
WITH ME. TWO TESTIMONY. NOW
WOULD BE THE TIME. ALL RIGHT.
ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T WANT TO BE
THE LEAD WITNESS IN OPPOSITION,
BUT WOULD LIKE TO ME TO NOT
SUPPORTING AB 2248 NOW WOULD BE
THE TIME. SEE THERE ALL STUCK IN
TRAFFIC. SEE? NO IT'S JUST A
WILDLY POPULAR BILL. I THINK
THAT'S WHAT IT IS. ALL RIGHT, SO
MOVE. YOU HAVE A MOTION. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. CAN
WE GET TO ASK QUESTIONS OR WOULD
YOU LIKE TO ASK A QUESTION? I'D
LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT. OKAY.
MAKE A COMMENT. YOU ARE MORE
THAN WELCOME. THIS MIGHT BE OUR
LAST TIME DOING THIS. I REALLY
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR
LEADERSHIP THAT YOU HAVE SHOWN
IN THIS SPACE. AND I THINK
YOU'VE YOU'VE MADE A BIG
DIFFERENCE TO ANIMALS IN
CALIFORNIA. SO I JUST I JUST
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU. MR. WILK. THANKS. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS? COMMENTS FROM
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ASHLEY I VOTE THEN WE WILL
CALL THE ROLL AB 2248
MAIENSCHEIN DO PASS TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN. AYE
ALVARADO. GIL. ALVARADO. GIL.
AYE. ARCHULETA Ã. ARCHULETA.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE. DODD
EGGMAN. GLAZER. MENGIBAR
MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO. NILO. AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK. AYE. WILK. AYE
56789990. WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL
AND HOLD ON TO IT FOR OUR
COLLEAGUES WHO AREN'T QUITE HERE
YET. ALL RIGHT, MR. MAIENSCHEIN,
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN,
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT 2270?
YES, THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM
CHAIR. AND MEMBERS, ACCORDING TO
THE NATIONAL LIBRARY OF
MEDICINE, UNDER MENOPAUSE IS
CRUCIAL FOR BOTH THE INDIVIDUALS
EXPERIENCING IT AND FOR HEALTH
CARE PROFESSIONALS ALIKE.
HOWEVER, DESPITE ITS
SIGNIFICANCE, THERE EXISTS A
WIDESPREAD MISCONCEPTION
SURROUNDING MENOPAUSE. THIS
LEADS TO A LACK OF UNDERSTANDING
FOR THOSE EXPERIENCING IT AND
DELAYS IN RECEIVING APPROPRIATE
CARE. AB 2270 AIMS TO ADDRESS
THIS BY ALLOWING MEDICAL AND
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS
TO SATISFY CONTINUING ED
REQUIREMENTS BY TAKING A COURSE
IN MENOPAUSAL MENTAL OR PHYSICAL
HEALTH, BY INCREASING AWARENESS
AND UNDERSTANDING OF THE ISSUES
SURROUNDING MENOPAUSE, WE CAN
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS RECEIVE
THE CARE AND SUPPORT THEY NEED.
THANK YOU, AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. DO YOU HAVE
A LEAD WITNESS MEMBER? I, I
MEAN, YOU'RE WELCOME TO TESTIFY,
SIR. ABSOLUTELY DAVID BULLOCK,
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY ALLIANCE
SERVING FAMILY VALUES. WE'RE
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS THIS
LEGISLATION. MENOPAUSE IS
SOMETHING THAT WILL AFFECT ALL
OF US IF WE LIVE LONG ENOUGH. IT
HAS MORE SEVERE EFFECTS ON SOME
THAN OTHERS. IT USUALLY IS MORE
HARSH ON OUR FEMALE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY. I HAVE PERSONALLY,
PERSONALLY WITNESSED MY MOTHER'S
MENOPAUSE COMPOUND OTHER
DETRIMENTAL HEALTH ISSUES SHE
WAS GOING THROUGH, ESCALATING TO
AN EARLY DEATH FOR HER. I'M
CURRENTLY WATCHING A CLOSE
FRIEND HAVING THIS AFFECT HER
LIFE IN A NOT SO PLEASANT WAY.
ONE STUDY REPORTS MENOPAUSE
BEING MISDIAGNOSED AS A MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUE 85% OF THE TIME,
WITH UNNECESSARY PHARMACEUTICALS
BEING PRESCRIBED. ALTHOUGH
ANTIDEPRESSANTS MAY MASK ONE OR
MORE SYMPTOMS, THIS TREATMENT
DOES NOT ADDRESS THE HORMONAL
IMBALANCE AT THE ROOT OF THIS
PROBLEM, WHICH MAY BE CAUSING
ADDITIONAL SYMPTOMS AS WELL. THE
MORE THAT COULD BE UNDERSTOOD BY
MEDICAL PROFESSIONALS, THE
BETTER OFF CALIFORNIA WILL BE IN
HELPING PEOPLE WHO SUFFER DURING
THIS STAGE OF MATURATION. THAT
UNDERSTANDING SHOULD RESULT IN
BETTER QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
PEOPLE GOING THROUGH MENOPAUSE.
LET IS MANY TIMES INCREMENTAL,
MEANING IT BUILDS ON ITSELF. I
HOPE THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WILL
BLOSSOM IN LEGISLATION SESSIONS
IN YEARS TO HEAD TO WHERE WE
START HAVING MORE ENCOURAGEMENT
OF STUDY OF THIS SUBJECT IN THE
HEALING ARTS, AND MORE PUBLIC
RECOGNITION OF THIS SUBJECT, WE
HUMBLY REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE ON
THIS TODAY. OKAY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THERE ANYONE ELSE WISHING
TO TESTIFY IN FAVOR OF AB 2270?
YOU CAN TAKE ME TO TESTIMONY NOW
TOO, IF YOU'D LIKE. WELCOME.
GOOD MORNING. SYMPHONY BARBEE,
ON BEHALF OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU, THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
OPPOSITION OPPOSING AB 2270 OR
FOLKS WHO WOULD JUST LIKE TO
CHIME IN AND SAY THEY OPPOSE AB
2270, SEEING NO ONE? I'LL BRING
IT BACK TO THE DAIS. COLLEAGUES,
DO YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS? SO
MOVE. MR. MAIENSCHEIN, WOULD YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CALL
THE ROLL AB 2270 MAIENSCHEIN
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. ASHBY
Ã. ASHBY. AYE AND NGUYEN.
NGUYEN I ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA I.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER I.
BECKER. AYE. DODD. EGGMAN
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. MENGIBAR
NILO. MENGIBAR I NILO NILO AYE.
ROTH. ROTH AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. WILK AYE. WILK I SO TEN.
10 TO 0. OKAY. 10 TO 0. WE'LL
PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL AS WELL
AND MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCHIN'S LAST BILL IN FRONT OF
US TODAY. AB 2581. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS ARE THE MOST
COMMON COMPLICATION OF PREGNANCY
AND BIRTH, IMPACTING 1 IN 5 75%
OF PEOPLE IMPACTED BY MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS REMAIN
UNTREATED, INCREASING THE RISK
OF LONG TERM NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON
MOTHERS, BABIES AND FAMILIES.
GIVING ALL HEALTH CARE AND
HEALTH PROVIDERS TRAINING IN
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH IS
ESSENTIAL. THIS WILL PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE TOOLS TO SUPPORT
PATIENTS EFFECTIVELY BOTH DURING
AND AFTER PREGNANCY. AB 2581
EXPANDS ON MY BILL AB 845 FROM
2019 AND EXTENDS THE CONTINUING
EDUCATION REQUIREMENTS FOR
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH FROM
PHYSICIANS AND SURGEONS TO ALL
MEDICAL AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS. AB 2581 WOULD
ALLOW CONTINUING EDUCATION
REQUIREMENTS FOR HEALTH CARE AND
HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO BE
SATISFIED WITH A COURSE IN
MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH. BY DOING
SO, WE EMPOWER OUR HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS, ENABLING THEM TO
UNDERSTAND MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH AND TREAT THEIR PATIENTS
EFFECTIVELY. THANK YOU. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. I SEE YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES READY. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. RYAN SPENCER, ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYNS, DISTRICT NINE, IN
SUPPORT OF AB 2581 MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS,
INCLUDING DEPRESSION, ANXIETY
AND PERINATAL MOOD DISORDERS
AFFECT SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
WOMEN DURING THE PREGNANCY AND
THE POSTPARTUM PERIOD. THESE
CONDITIONS NOT ONLY IMPACT THE
WELL-BEING OF THE MOTHER, BUT
ALSO HAVE PROFOUND EFFECTS ON
THE HEALTH AND DEVELOPMENT OF
THE NEWBORN. BY PROVIDING AN
OPTION FOR PROVIDERS TO BE
EDUCATED ON MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH, THEY COULD BE EQUIPPED
WITH THE KNOWLEDGE AND SKILLS
NECESSARY TO RECOGNIZE THE SIGNS
AND SYMPTOMS OF MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS, CONDUCT
APPROPRIATE SCREENINGS, AND
PROVIDE OR REFER FOR NECESSARY
TREATMENT. EVANS SUGGESTS THAT
EARLY IDENTIFICATION AND
INTERVENTION FOR MATERNAL MENTAL
HEALTH CONDITIONS CAN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR BOTH THEIR MOTHER AND CHILD
TRAINED. THEREFORE, SHOULD THERE
TRAINING SHOULD THEREFORE NOT
ONLY FOCUS ON DIAGNOSIS BUT ALSO
CREATE AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE
WOMEN FEEL SUPPORTED AND
EMPOWERED TO SEEK HELP FOR
WITHOUT FEAR OF JUDGMENT.
FURTHERMORE, ACOG ADVOCATES FOR
A MULTIDISCIPLINARY APPROACH IN
THE MANAGEMENT OF MATERNAL
MENTAL HEALTH INVOLVING
COLLABORATION BETWEEN
OBSTETRICIANS, MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS, PEDIATRICIANS,
AND OTHER RELEVANT HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS. THIS COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY ENSURES THAT WOMEN
RECEIVE HOLISTIC CARE THEY NEED
DURING THIS VULNERABLE PERIOD,
HELPING AN ARRAY OF HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO BETTER IDENTIFY AND
MANAGE MENTAL HEALTH CONDITIONS
IS A DIRECT INVESTMENT IN THE
HEALTH AND WELL-BEING OF THEIR
MOTHERS AND THEIR CHILDREN. AB
2581 PROVIDES THIS PATHWAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK
YOU. DO YOU HAVE ANY OTHER LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? OKAY,
SURE. BRIEFLY DAVID BULLDOG,
S.F. VÆ ALLIANCE MATERNAL
DEPRESSION IS REAL.
UNFORTUNATELY, HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS, FAMILY AND
FRIENDS TEND TO FOCUS ON THE
PHYSICAL HEALTH OF THE MOTHER
AND CHILD AND TEND TO FORGET
ABOUT THE HORMONAL CHANGE IN
PREGNANT AND POSTNATAL WOMEN.
THOSE OF YOU WHO HAVE BIRTHED A
CHILD ALREADY UNDERSTAND THIS.
THIS BILL WILL AID CALIFORNIA
MOTHERS DURING AND AFTER THEIR
PREGNANCY TO A BETTERMENT FOR
OVERALL HEALTH OF THE OF THE
MOTHER. THIS WILL BE A
BENEFICIAL NOT ONLY FOR THE
MOTHER AND HER FAMILY, BUT HER
COWORKERS AND FRIENDS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANY ME TO TESTIMONY IN THE
ROOM FOR AB 2581?
HELLO SYMPHONY BABI, ON BEHALF
OF PLANNED PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES
OF CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. GREAT. ANYONE OPPOSED TO AB
2581? ALL RIGHT, BRING IT BACK
TO THE DÍAS. ANYBODY HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR? SEEING
NONE. THE BILL IS MOVED. WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AND I VOTE.
ALL RIGHT. WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
AB 2581 MAIENSCHEIN DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. BURNS. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN NGUYEN.
AYE. ALVARADO. GIL ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA. AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. DODD DODD. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GLASER. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO
NILO AYE. ROTH. ROTH AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WILK. WILK.
AYE ALL RIGHT, THAT'S 12. OH,
WE'LL PUT IT ON CALL. THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR BEING HERE, MEMBERS.
ALL RIGHT. WE ARE WAITING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZUBER. BUT IN
THE MEANTIME, I HAVE A COUPLE OF
THINGS WE CAN DO HERE.
COLLEAGUES, I AM VERY SORRY. I
KNOW YOU PREPARED FOR THESE
ITEMS TO BE ON THE AGENDA TODAY.
WE, OUR STAFF, RECEIVED A LAST
MINUTE NOTICE REQUEST FROM THE
AUTHOR TO, PULL FILE ITEMS
NUMBER SIX AND SEVEN, WHICH IS
AB 2860 AND AB 2864. THANK YOU
FOR BEING PREPARED FOR THOSE
ITEMS. WE'RE GOING TO PULL THEM
FOR NOW AT THE AUTHOR'S REQUEST.
ALL RIGHT. AND THEN YES, I HAVE
A LITTLE HOUSE CLEANING. YOU
HAVE TO CLEAN YOUR HOUSE. NO,
THANKS FOR SHARING. YOU KNOW,
BUT I'D LIKE TO WISH SENATOR
NEELO A HAPPY BELATED BIRTHDAY.
IT WAS HIS BIRTHDAY ON SATURDAY.
HAPPY BIRTHDAY TO SENATOR NILO.
THANK YOU FOR THAT. BUT MINE WAS
ON SUNDAY. SENATOR ARCHULETA'S
WAS ON SATURDAY. OKAY. ALSO,
HAPPY BIRTHDAY, SENATOR
ARCHULETA. AND TODAY IS SENATOR
CORTEZ'S BIRTHDAY. OH MY
GOODNESS. IT'S A BUSY, BUSY
BIRTHDAY SEASON. OKAY, WE'RE
GOING TO OPEN THE ROLL AND LET
SOME OF YOU GET ON THESE ITEMS.
LET'S GO BACK TO CONSENT. IF YOU
WOULDN'T MIND CALLING THE ABSENT
MEMBERS, CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT ZERO. CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
ALVARADO GILL. Ã ALVARADO. GILL
I DODD I DODD I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. GLASER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS GREAT. IF YOU COULD CALL
FILE ITEM TWO AB 2248 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MAIENSCHEIN.
THIS IS, CONTRACTS FOR SALE OF
DOGS AND CATS ONLINE. IF YOU
COULD CALL THAT FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CURRENT VOTE. EXCUSE
ME. CURRENT VOTE. NINE ZERO.
CHAIR. VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE.
DODD DODD I EGGMAN. EGGMAN I
GLASER. GLASER I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS. OKAY, THAT'S 12 ZERO.
WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON CALL AS
WELL AND MOVE TO FILE ITEM THREE
AB 2270 BY MAIENSCHEIN. THIS IS
HIS HEALING ARTS MENOPAUSE BILL,
CURRENT VOTE TEN ZERO. CHAIR.
VICE CHAIR. VOTING AYE. DODD I
DODD I GLASER. GLASER I
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. THAT'S 12.
NOTHING. WE'LL PUT THAT BACK ON
CALL AS WELL. AND I BELIEVE WE
HAVE EVERYONE HERE FOR ITEM
FOUR. SO WE WILL AWAIT THE
ARRIVAL OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER SOBER
.
NICK OF TIME. ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
HAPPY TO SEE YOU. FEEL FREE TO
COME FORWARD AND PRESENT. AB
2442. YOUR SENATE COLLEAGUES
AWAIT. PODIUM IS GREAT. IT'S
BEEN A YEAR, SO WELCOME BACK.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO
PRESENT AB 2442, WHICH IS
SPONSORED BY PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA AND
EQUALITY CALIFORNIA. THIS BILL
SEEKS TO IMPROVE ACCESS TO
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE IN
ANTICIPATION OF A SURGE OF OUT
OF STATE PATIENTS SEEKING SUCH
CARE IN CALIFORNIA IN RECENT
YEARS, THE NUMBER OF STATES WITH
LAWS OR POLICIES RESTRICTING
ACCESS TO GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
HAS INCREASED DRAMATICALLY.
CLIMBING FROM JUST FOUR STATES
IN JUNE 20TH 22 TO 23 STATES IN
2024. THESE LAWS AND POLICIES
OFTEN IMPOSE SEVERE PROFESSIONAL
OR CRIMINAL PENALTIES ON MEDICAL
PROVIDERS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS OFFERING GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE, MAKING IT HARDER
FOR PEOPLE TO ACCESS GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE IN THOSE STATES.
THIS GENDER AFFIRMING CARE IS A
IS HIGHLY SPECIALIZED, AND THESE
BARS IN OTHER STATES ARE
REQUIRING PATIENTS TO TRAVEL TO
STATES LIKE CALIFORNIA TO OBTAIN
THE HEALTH CARE THAT THEY NEED.
AB 2024 2442 SEEKS TO IMPROVE
ACCESS TO THIS CARE IN
ANTICIPATION OF THE SURGE IN OUT
OF STATE PATIENTS. THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY REQUIRES THE
EXPEDITED PROCESSING OF
LICENSURE APPLICATIONS FOR
PROVIDERS, DEMONSTRATING A
COMMITMENT TO GENDER AFFIRMING
HEALTH CARE OR MENTAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES WITHIN THEIR
LICENSED SCOPE OF PRACTICE.
CALIFORNIA HAS LONG SERVED AS A
SAFE HAVEN FOR REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE AND GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE. AB 2442 REFLECTS OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO UPHOLDING
THESE VALUES AND ENSURING
EQUITABLE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
SERVICES WITH ME TODAY ARE CRAIG
PULSIPHER, REPRESENTING EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA AND SYMPHONY BARBIE
WITH PLANNED PARENTHOOD
AFFILIATES OF CALIFORNIA, TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL INFORMATION
AND ASSIST WITH QUESTIONS.
GREAT. WE'LL HEAR FROM YOUR LEAD
WITNESSES, GOOD MORNING, CHAIR
AND MEMBERS, CRAIG PULSIPHER, ON
BEHALF OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA,
PROUD TO CO-SPONSOR THIS BILL TO
ENSURE THAT TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY HAVE ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL
HEALTH CARE, AS THIS MEMBER
NOTED OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS, WE'VE WITNESSED GROWING
EFFORTS TO RESTRICT ACCESS TO
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE, CARE THAT
IS INFORMED BY DECADES OF
RESEARCH AND SUPPORTED BY EVERY
MAJOR MEDICAL ASSOCIATION IN THE
COUNTRY. CURRENTLY, 24 STATES
HAVE ENACTED LAWS THAT BAN
ACCESS TO GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
FOR TRANS YOUTH. 19 OF THESE
BANS WERE ENACTED IN THE LAST
YEAR ALONE, ACCORDING TO THE
WILLIAMS INSTITUTE AT THE UCLA
SCHOOL OF LAW, MORE THAN A THIRD
OF TRANS YOUTH IN THE US NOW
LIVE IN STATES THAT HAVE ENACTED
BANS ON ACCESS TO GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE, AND MANY
FAMILIES IN THESE STATES ARE NOW
FACING AGONIZING DECISIONS ABOUT
WHETHER TO RELOCATE OR TRAVEL
OUT OF STATE TO ACCESS THE
HEALTH CARE THEY NEED, OVER THE
LAST SEVERAL YEARS, CALIFORNIA
HAS ENACTED NUMEROUS PROTECTIONS
TO ENSURE THAT THE STATE IS A
SAFE HAVEN FOR THOSE WHO MAY
NEED TO COME HERE TO ACCESS CARE
FOR THEMSELVES OR A LOVED ONE.
AND AB 2442 BUILDS ON THOSE
EFFORTS BY EXPEDITING LICENSURE
FOR PROVIDERS OF GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE TO ENSURE THAT
THE STATE HAS A ROBUST NETWORK
OF PROVIDERS TO MEET THE
POTENTIAL INFLUX OF NEW
PATIENTS. AT THE SAME TIME, THE
BILL WILL HELP TO IMPROVE ACCESS
FOR TRANSGENDER CALIFORNIANS,
WHO MUST OFTEN WAIT MONTHS TO
ACCESS CARE. GIVEN THE LIMITED
NUMBER OF PROVIDERS AVAILABLE.
IMPORTANTLY, THE BILL HAS A
SUNSET CLAUSE SO THAT WE CAN
REEVALUATE THE ONGOING NEED FOR
THIS BILL IN FOUR YEARS AND
WOULD JUST FLAG THE SOME OF THE
CONCERNS FROM THE OPPOSITION
THAT WERE RAISED IN THE ANALYSIS
THAT THIS IS SOMEHOW RUSHING
APPROVAL IN A WAY THAT WOULD
SOMEHOW NEGATIVELY IMPACT THE
QUALITY OF CARE PROVIDED AND
WOULD JUST HIGHLIGHT THE FACT
THAT THE BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
LICENSING REQUIREMENTS OR
UNDERMINE EXISTING STANDARDS IN
ANY WAY. IT MERELY PRIORITIZES
APPLICATIONS TO GET PROVIDERS
WORKING IN CALIFORNIA AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE AND RESPECTFULLY
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. NEXT, LEAD
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. GOOD
MORNING, CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS
SYMPHONY BARBIE WITH PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES OF
CALIFORNIA. ON BEHALF OF THE
SEVEN AFFILIATES WHO PROVIDE
CARE THROUGH OVER 100 HEALTH
CENTERS IN THE STATE, HERE IS A
PROUD CO-SPONSOR OF AB 2442 TO
IMPROVE ACCESS TO GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE IS LIFE SAVING CARE THAT
HAS POSITIVE IMPACTS ON T.G.I.
PATIENTS INCLUDE REDUCED RATES
OF DEPRESSION AND ANXIETY.
DESPITE THE POSITIVE IMPACT
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE HAS ON
PATIENTS. AS NOTED, 23 TO 24
STATES HAVE ENACTED RESTRICTIONS
ON THIS ESSENTIAL CARE ATTACKS
ON GENDER AFFIRMING CARE
THREATEN THE ABILITY FOR PEOPLE
TO ACCESS CARE THAT THEY NEED IN
ORDER TO LIVE FULL AND HEALTHY
LIVES. THE ATTACK ON GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE ALSO CLOSELY
MIRRORS THE ATTACKS ON ABORTION
AND CARE, PLACING BARRIERS ON
THIS CARE TO GENDER AFFIRMING
CARE, WHICH CAN ALREADY BE
DIFFICULT TO NAVIGATE AND ACCESS
IN CALIFORNIA, ONLY FURTHER
EXACERBATES HEALTH CARE
DISPARITIES. AB 2442 SEEKS TO
ENSURE THAT LICENSURE
APPLICATIONS FOR PROVIDERS OF
GENDER AFFIRMING CARE ARE
PRIORITIZED TO ENSURE A ROBUST
NETWORK OF TRAINED PROVIDERS AND
A TIMELY ACCESS TO CARE FOR
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA. I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR VOTE ON
AB 2442 TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU FOR TESTIMONY. WILL TAKE ME
TO TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT YOUR
NAME, AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. RYAN SPENCER
BEHALF. THE AMERICAN COLLEGE OF
OBGYNS DISTRICT NINE, IN SUPPORT
BECCA KRAMER MATTER ON BEHALF OF
ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
SUPPORT. RYAN SOUZA ON BEHALF OF
ESSENTIAL HEALTH ACCESS AND APLA
HEALTH IN SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING,
GENESIS GONZALES, ON BEHALF OF
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ELENI
KOUNALAKIS IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
. OKAY, NOW WE WILL TAKE LEAD
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. YOU'LL
EACH HAVE TWO MINUTES TO OF. YOU
CAN SPEAK, AND THEN WE'LL TAKE
ME TO TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION.
CHAIR MEMBERS, MY NAME IS GREG
BURT, VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY COUNCIL. AND
WE STRONGLY OPPOSE AB 242
BECAUSE IT GRANTS SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES, AND TO MEDICAL
PERSONNEL WHO ARE USING
TREATMENTS FOR GENDER DYSPHORIA,
WHICH OTHER COUNTRIES ARE
REJECTING FOR THE HORROR HARM
THEY CAUSE TO MINORS. YOU SHOULD
HAVE RECEIVED A COPY OF A STUDY
PUBLISHED IN THE NATIONAL
LIBRARY OF MEDICINE, SHOWING AN
INCREASED RISK OF SUICIDE OF
THOSE WHO RECEIVED GENDER
AFFIRMING SURGERY, WE HAVE ALSO
SENT YOU ARTICLES REGARDING THE
CAS REVIEW. IT'S AN INDEPENDENT
REVIEW COMMISSIONED BY THE
ENGLISH GOVERNMENT, WHICH
HIGHLIGHTS A SIGNIFICANT RISK
AND ADVERSE OUTCOMES ASSOCIATED
WITH GENDER AFFIRMING TREATMENTS
SUCH AS PUBERTY BLOCKERS AND
CROSS-SEX HORMONES. JUST LAST
WEEK, UNITED KINGDOM BANNED
PRIVATE DOCTORS FROM PRESCRIBING
AND SUPPLYING PUBERTY BLOCKERS
FOR MINORS. THIS EMERGENCY
ORDER, LIKELY TO BECOME
PERMANENT, FOLLOWS THE NATIONAL
HEALTH SERVICE'S DECISION TO
CEASE PRESCRIBING THESE
TREATMENTS OUTSIDE OF RESEARCH
SETTINGS. THESE ACTIONS ARE
GROUNDED IN THE FINDINGS OF THE
CAS REVIEW, WHICH RAISE CRITICAL
CONCERNS ABOUT SOCIAL
TRANSITIONING OF MINORS,
EMPHASIZING THAT SUCH TRANSITION
OPTIONS ARE PROFOUND
PSYCHOLOGICAL INTERVENTIONS WITH
POTENTIALLY IRREVERSIBLE
CONSEQUENCES. THE CAS REVIEW
ALSO FOUND THE EVIDENCE
SUPPORTING THESE TREATMENTS TO
BE DISAPPOINTINGLY POOR, AND
HIGHLIGHTED THE FREQUENT
CO-OCCURRENCE OF GENDER
DYSPHORIA, GENDER DYSPHORIA WITH
OTHER ACUTE MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES
THAT MUST BE ADDRESSED FIRST.
FINLAND, SWEDEN, NORWAY, FRANCE,
DENMARK, SCOTLAND AND ITALY HAVE
ALL RECENTLY REVERSED COURSE AND
PLACED RESTRICTIONS ON
MEDICALIZING CHILDREN WITH
GENDER DYSPHORIA THAT FAVOR
PSYCHOLOGICAL TREATMENT WITHOUT
AUTOMATIC AFFIRMATION. THÀNH
WITH ALL THIS EVIDENCE, WHY
THEN, IS THIS LEGISLATURE AND
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS? THAT'S
TWO MINUTES GOING TO NEED YOU TO
GIVE US YOUR FINAL THOUGHT THERE
AND LET THE OTHER LEAD WITNESS
SPEAK. SURE. GIVING ALL THIS
WITNESS. WHY IS THIS, THE
ANALYSIS IN THIS LEGISLATURE
CONTINUING TO SUPPORT, THESE,
TREATMENTS WITHOUT BRINGING UP
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OTHER
COUNTRIES? THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY. NEXT LEAD WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION. TWO MINUTES. GOOD
MORNING. MY NAME IS AARON.
FRIDAY OUR DUTY DEMOCRAT. THIS
BILL GIVES PREFERENTIAL
TREATMENT FOR PROVIDERS WILLING
TO BE LIKE MENGELE. REMOVAL OF
WOMEN'S OVARIES TO TREAT MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES. USED TO BE THE
RAGE. LOBOTOMIES TO TODAY WE ARE
REMOVING BODY PARTS, ADDING FAKE
ONES TO CURE A MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUE, GENDER DYSPHORIA OR
WORSE, SUPPORT A SEXUAL FETISH.
CAS CHLOE COLE WAS AFFIRMED AT
AGE 12. SHE WENT ON PUBERTY
BLOCKERS, TESTOSTERONE AND HAD
HER BREASTS AMPUTATED AT AGE 15,
SHE DETRANSITIONED. AT 17, SHE
IS AUTISTIC. CAS ABLE GARCIA WAS
AFFIRMED DESPITE BEING AUTISTIC
WHEN HE DETRANSITIONED HE
COULDN'T GET INSURANCE TO REMOVE
HIS FAKE BREASTS. GUESS SHE
CAN'T BE AFFIRMED FOR YOUR
BIOLOGICAL SEX. HIS BODY SHAKES
UNCONTROLLABLY AND HIS GENITALS
HAVE ATROPHIED. CAS LAYLA JANE
WAS AFFIRMED AND HAD HER BREASTS
SLICED OFF A COUPLE WEEKS AFTER
SHE TURNED 13. DESPITE HAVING A
LONG HISTORY OF ACUTE MENTAL
HEALTH ISSUES, SHE
DETRANSITIONED CALIFORNIA'S
CAROL F WAS AFFIRMED AND HER
FEMALE VOICE, HER HAIR AND HER
BREASTS WERE TAKEN. SHE GOT OVER
THE SHAME OF BEING A BUTCH
LESBIAN AND DETRANSITIONED,
CALIFORNIA'S RICHARD NEWNHAM WAS
RAPED BY HIS NIGERIAN BROTHER,
ABUSED BY HIS PARENTS, HAS
BIPOLAR AND SCHIZOPHRENIA. THIS
WAS KNOWN TO HIS DOCTORS, BUT HE
WAS AFFIRMED AND HE NO LONGER
HAS A PENIS. MY DAUGHTER WAS 13
WHEN SHE WAS AFFIRMED, BUT I
PULLED HER OUT OF HER
SELF-LOATHING BEFORE THE
SCALPELS COULD REACH HER, AND
SHE RE-IDENTIFIED AS THE
BEAUTIFUL GIRL THAT SHE ALWAYS
WAS. CAS DAVID BACON WAS
AFFIRMED. HE GOT A PAIR OF
BREASTS AND ESTROGEN THAT
RESULTED IN SEVERE HEART ISSUES.
HE DETRANSITIONED CAS. MADDIE
WAS AFFIRMED AND SHE HAD HER
HEALTHY BREASTS. OKAY, MA'AM,
THAT'S TWO MINUTES. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. YOU CAN GIVE
US A FINAL THOUGHT, OKAY?
AFFIRMING THAT ONE ONE'S BODY IS
WRONG AND THAT MUST BE FIXED IS
NOT JUST MALPRACTICE, BUT IT'S
CRUEL. VOTE NO ON AB 244. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'LL
TAKE ME TO TESTIMONY IN
OPPOSITION. NOW, JUST YOUR NAME,
ORGANIZATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. GOOD MORNING SENATORS. MY
NAME IS DAVID BULLOCK. I'M
REPRESENTING THE SFP ALLIANCE,
THE LA COUNTY CHAPTER FOR MOMS
FOR LIBERTY, THE TRUTH EXCHANGE,
TAXPAYER OVERSIGHT FOR PARENTS
AND CHILDREN, THE FACTS LAW,
TRUTH, JUSTICE, LAW FIRM AND
TAKE A STAND. STANISLAUS. THANK
YOU, THANK YOU. ANYONE ELSE? ALL
RIGHT, BACK TO THE DAIS. ANYBODY
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR? WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ZEBRA? THE ONE
THING I'LL SAY IS THAT THIS
DOESN'T CREATE ANY SPECIAL
PRIVILEGES. IT DOESN'T CHANGE
ANY OF THE STANDARDS THAT ARE
MENTAL HEALTH. AND OUR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS ARE HOLD
THEMSELVES TO. ALL IT DOES IS IT
BASICALLY PRIORITIZES THE, THE,
THE, THE PROCESSING OF THE, OF
THE MEDICAL LICENSING IN THIS
AREA. AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. ALL RIGHT. THE ITEM
HAS BEEN MOVED. WE WILL TAKE A
ROLL CALL. VOTE SB 2442. OH, I
DID ASK FOR COMMENTS. QUESTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A COMMENT
OR A QUESTION? GO AHEAD.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S BURR, I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY,
AND BRINGING UP THIS ISSUE, IT'S
RARE THAT I SIT HERE AND, READ
THROUGH THE OPPOSITION SUPPORT
LETTERS AND GET A VISCERAL
RESPONSE, I DO READ EVERYTHING
THAT COMES TO US. BUT I COULD
NOT GET THROUGH THE LETTERS IN
THE OPPOSITION, AND SO I JUST
WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR YOUR
BRAVERY IN THIS, IT IS, IS
COURAGEOUS AND NECESSARY TO COME
FORWARD WITH WHAT IS RIGHT, AND
TO PUSH BACK ON IDEOLOGIES. AND
THIS IS ABOUT HEALTH CARE
ACCESS, AND THIS IS ABOUT,
DIGNITY AND RESPECT FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS, SO THANK YOU. AND
I, I DON'T FEEL I NEED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE OPPOSITION,
BUT I DO FEEL I NEED TO
RECOGNIZE FOR ME THAT VISCERAL
RESPONSE OF READING THE LETTERS.
SO THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
SAYING THAT. ALL RIGHT. YOU HAVE
A MOTION. WE WILL CALL THE ROLL
AB 2442 Dð PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. ASHBY. AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. NGUYEN. NGUYEN NO.
ALVARADO. GIL. AYE. ALVARADO.
GIL. AYE. ARCHULETA AYE.
ARCHULETA. AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE DODD. DODD. AYE. EGGMAN.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER GLAZER. AYE.
MENGIBAR. MENGIBAR. AYE. NILO NO
NILO NO. ROTH. ROTH. AYE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. WILK. WILK. NO
ALL RIGHT. THAT'S 9 TO 3. WE'LL
PUT THAT ITEM ON CALL. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ZUBER. COLLEAGUES, IF YOU HAVE
ALREADY VOTED ON ALL THE BILLS,
YOU HAVE FULFILLED YOUR DUTIES
FOR BUSINESS, PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT. THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE. WE WILL HOLD THE
ROLL OPEN FOR ANOTHER MOMENT,
FOR SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS,
WHO IS ON HER WAY DOWN.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO OPEN
THE ROLL AND CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS HERE. LET'S START WITH
THE CONSENT CALENDAR. CONSENT
CALENDAR. OOPS CONSENT CALENDAR.
CURRENT ZERO. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS,
I MOORLACH RIVAS I. GREAT.
CONSENT IS 13 TO NOTHING. AND ON
ITS WAY. AND THEN FILE ITEM TWO
MAIN SHINE A B 2248 WHICH SITS
AT 12 TO NOTHING RIGHT NOW.
CHAIR AND VICE CHAIR VOTING AYE.
DO PASS TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS I SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS I GREAT 13 TO NOTHING.
THAT BILL IS OUT FILE ITEM THREE
AB 2270 MAIN SHRINE. THIS IS HIS
HEALING ARTS ON MENOPAUSE. IT
SITS AT 12 ZERO WITH THE CHAIR
AND VICE CHAIR VOTING NO, I MEAN
I SORRY VOTING. I DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
I SMOKE RIVAS I GREAT 13 TO
NOTHING. THAT BILL IS OUT AND
FILE ITEM FOUR ALSO MOONSHINE A
B 2581. THIS IS HIS HEALING ARTS
ON MATERNAL MENTAL HEALTH. IT
SITS AT 12. NOTHING I DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS A GREAT 13
TO NOTHING. THAT BILL IS OUT AND
FINALLY FILE ITEM FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S BIRTHS. A B
2442 HEALING ARTS EXPEDITED
LICENSURE PROCESS FOR GENDER,
GENDER AFFIRMING HEALTH CARE. IT
SITS AT NINE EYES AND THREE NO'S
CHAIR VOTING AYE. VICE CHAIR
VOTING NO. DO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
I SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS A GREAT 10
TO 3. THAT ITEM IS OUT AS WELL.
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS ITEMS
SIX AND SEVEN WERE BOTH PULLED
BY THE AUTHOR. SO THAT IS THE
TOTALITY OF OUR AGENDA TODAY.
THANKS FOR COMING DOWN. ALL
RIGHT. AND THAT'S IT FOR
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT TODAY.
WE'RE ADJOURNED.